in terms of the matter of titles yes we
can expect some changes um it is more
likely than notch that prince william
the duke of cambridge will become the
prince of wales and catherine in turn
the princess of wales they will also
inherit a number of other titles through
charles who will relinquish the prince
of wales title now that he is king
charles iii what we do know about the
titles is that king charles has decided
to be king charles iii and we do know
that we now have queen consort camilla
of course the queen used that
anniversary of her accession for her
70th to make it known that it was her
express wish for camilla to become queen
consort the moment the queen's heart
stopped beating
charles became king charles camilla
became queen consort we haven't had a
princess of wales since diana camilla
chose the title of the duchess of
cambridge because it would not have been
accepted at that time for her to become
the princess of wales a title that she
was actually entitled to catherine we
understand will inherit that title there
have been inevitable comparisons between
catherine and the princess of wales ever
since she got engaged to prince william
i think one of the duchess of
cambridge's greatest
successes has been creating a new role
from herself away from the shadows of
princess diana of course she was always
going to inherit the title the princess
of wales and she more than anyone will
know that they are sizable shoes to fill
at present there is no official
confirmation of the timeline of
charles's coronation but all the sources
who i have spoken to including from my
book the new royals suggest that charles
will have a coronation far sooner than
his mother's coronation there was a full
year between the death of king george vi
and the coronation of queen elizabeth
this is going to be a much shorter time
period the prince of wales has been our
longest serving prince of wales the
longest king in waiting and i expect
that his coronation will be certainly in
a matter of months rather than a year
[Music]